We are absolutely destroying these horrible
regulations.
I haven’t seen anything like the regulatory
reductions that have taken place.
Let’s cut the red tape.
Who is in favor of regulations that aren't
working?
We have undertaken a historic effort to massively
reduce job-crushing regulations.
And we’re imposing a new rule which mandates
that for every one new regulation,
two old regulations must be eliminated.
Donald Trump promised at the beginning of
his presidency to slash regulations.
And after his first year, he’s delivered
more than almost anybody predicted.
Washington’s regulatory reformers have infiltrated
the halls of power
and are attempting to engineer the most ambitious
pruning of the executive branch
in over three decades.
It’s a bright spot in a presidency that
has otherwise been the opposite of libertarian:
trade wars, travel bans, and big-spending
increases.
Trump has appointed real reformers to carry
out his deregulatory agenda:
Betsy DeVos at Education, Rick Perry at Energy,
Scott Gottlieb at the Food and Drug Administration,
Ajit Pai at the FCC.
One of the most influential administrators
is Neomi Rao,
Trump’s appointee to oversee cost-benefit
analyses for the entire regulatory juggernaut,
who came to the White House after founding
the Center for the Study of the Administrative State
at George Mason University.
I think that there are a lot of very strongly
reform-minded people
who have come into the administration
and occupying a number of the senior political
appointments.
And they're very committed to regulatory reform
and rolling back some of these burdens that
had been imposed over the past 5, 10, 15 years.
So what has Trump deregulated?
In his first year the president signed 15
regulatory repeals via the Congressional Review Act,
or 14 more times than the law had been used
the previous two decades.
Gone are Obamacare’s Individual Mandate,
the EPA’s Clean Power Plan,
and the Department of Education’s kangaroo
court-style guidance on campus sexual assault.
In addition to the two-for-one executive order,
Trump has also required agencies to impose
an aggregate regulatory cost each year of zero.
The never-ending growth of red tape in America
has come to a sudden screeching and beautiful halt.
We’re not just going to eliminate some small,
insignificant rules,
but we also have to have a negative regulatory
cost budget.
Which is what we had for 2017, and we went
even below that.
And I think it's the first time, since at
least we have been keeping records,
that there has been a year like that.
You know we're also encouraging the agencies
to look at deregulation
not just from the numbers side.
Many agencies are peeling back guidance documents
or streamlining paperwork burdens,
and all of that I think is having an impact.
The free-market enthusiasts at the Competitive
Enterprise Institute,
a Washington, D.C. think tank,
have been tallying new regulations annually
for the past 25 years.
In 2017, they found the administration cut
the number of pages in the Federal Register
by more than a third.
And the 3,281 new rules amounted to:
“the lowest count since records began being
kept in the mid-1970s.”
I haven't seen personally anything like the
regulatory reductions that have taken place.
The Competitive Enterprise Institute’s Clyde
Wayne Crews
is already calling Donald Trump “the least
regulatory president of all.”
Trump has gone after, say for example, the
Waters of the United States rule.
The EPA’s so-called Waters of the United
States rule
is one of the worst examples of federal regulation.
It's welcoming to see the FCC turn back the
so-called net neutrality rule.
I'm impressed and unimpressed at the same
time.
I love what has happened, and I want it to
continue.
But to really address all that you’ve got
to get Congress to act.
In other words, the executive branch can rearrange
the scope and process of enforcement,
but only legislators can repeal the underlying
laws.
The million-dollar question is,
how much impact will the Trump administration’s regulatory tweaks have
on individual industries and the overall economy?
So by our very kind of conservative internal
estimates,
we estimate that the regulations that we've
pulled back are saving more than $8 billion dollars.
Maybe that sounds small,
but when you think about it in the context
that the cost of regulations increases every year,
I think it's actually pretty impressive.
I think another number that is important,
is that we are revisiting, or have postponed,
over 1,500 rules that were on the agenda.
Some of those rules may end up going forward,
but I think it demonstrates the magnitude
of what we're reconsidering.
Is this the first real challenge to the kind
of automatic growth of the regulatory state
that we've seen in a solid generation here?
I think so. Yes.
We have done more in our first year than any
president since we've been keeping records.
The numbers that had been reduced in the Trump
administration are pretty significant.
When he rolled back, or withdrew, or withheld
1,500 of Obama's regulations,
they were not all significant regulations
by any stretch.
But it's a start.
And remember, Obama said, "I have a pen and
phone, and if Congress doesn't act,
we can go around Congress and act."
Trump has a pen and phone, too.
Any president does.
And it can be used within the rule of law
to advance liberty rather than curtail it.
Though Trump met his target last year, can
he do it again?
Or has the easy stuff already been plucked?
I think in 2018, he's gonna have a much tougher
time.
The job of rolling back two for one, when
you're acting alone as president
and you can't make law on your own,
the barrier that you run into is you run out of low-hanging fruit.
So how much can you do now?
You've got two-for-one in place, I know you
want to try to do three-for-one next year,
but how much latitude does the executive branch
have?
There's plenty of bad regulation that's still
out there that we can work on rolling back.
To really get at, sort of, the core of the
regulatory state,
you're going to need statutory reform.
The House has passed a series of reform bills
that focus on the process by which the executive
branch makes its rules.
These have names like:
Searching for and Cutting Regulations that
are Unnecessarily Burdensome Act, or “SCRUB,”
the Regulations from the Executive in Need
of Scrutiny Act, or “REINS, and so on.
All are currently languishing in the Senate,
where the slim Republican majority
includes senators who’ve expressed concern
that deconstructing the administrative state
will have a negative impact on the health
and safety of Americans.
Now, your progressive friends will say that
what you're doing
is making the world more dangerous.
What's your basic response to that framework?
I think Congress has, through a massive mass
of statutes,
ensured essentially that we live in a very
highly regulated society.
There's a limit to how much the executive
branch can do to undo that,
and we're not looking to undo health and safety
protections that are required by law.
By definition the regulations that we're turning
back are not working for the public.
So can libertarians expect more progress in
the midterm election year of 2018?
To the extent regulatory reforms happen in
a year like this one,
that's going to be so contentious and already
is, I think it would be something lesser.
It would be something on the order of more
disclosure of regulations.
I know there's some bipartisan support for
that.
But sadly, in terms of rolling back regulations
this year, Trump is pretty much on his own.
What's in front of you?
We want to reduce the cumulative regulatory
burdens on the American people
as much as possible.
The agencies now really have to go back
andthink about which of their regulations are no longer working.
It's a good government policy.
Who is in favor of regulations that aren't
working?